en titre le choc evènement le duel de la
3e circonscription d'indre et loire
entre marisol touraine candidate
socialiste et sophie auconie candidate
du dlr un débat au sommet aujourd'hui
sur notre antenne animé par kébé tour
france bleu et la nouvelle république
parmi les thèmes abordés le soutien dans
marche la désertification médicale
la fracture numérique ou encore la crise
agricole
on retrouve avec nous florent clavel sur
ce plateau
vous allez animer ce débat est un débat
à couteaux tirés
elle a eu de réel moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que l'inimitié et la rivalité
que nourrissent les deux candidates
l'une envers l'autre et bien a pu se
vérifier très concrètement dès les
premiers échanges sur le plateau l'une
des polémiques qui a émergé bien c'est
celle de la légitimité à se présenter
sur cette troisième circonscription en
gros moi je connais le territoire patois
avec l'idée en toile de fond d'une
discréditer l'adversaire on écoute
lorsque j'étais ministre j'ai été amené
à porter un certain nombre de projets
pour ce territoire
je ne vous ai jamais vu l it et john est
venu me solliciter d'ailleurs pour quoi
que ce soit concernant ce territoire
sans doute étiez-vous davantage occupé
par vos fonctions de conseillère
municipale de tours et oriane une fois
de plus je n'ai pas de leçon de voir ces
flammes
quel est votre domicile en indre et
loire
vous n'avez de local que votre nom de
famille vous n'avez pas d'ancrage local
vous n'habitez pas la tour et j'ai
réveillé en bourgogne et vous habitez à
l'île d'yeu voilà pour la légitimité
vous avez évidemment abordé d'autres
sujets florent le rôle et le pouvoir du
député sur un certain nombre de sujets
nationaux et locaux comme la crise
agricole ou encore la fracture numérique
et surtout la désertification médicale
et oui un thème sensible puisqu'il
engage une partie du bilan de l'ex
ministre de la santé marisol touraine
un sujet central également en indre et
loire notamment sur la troisième
circonscription
rendez vous compte audrey un médecin
pour 400 patients seulement voilà alors
ce que les deux camps
elle propose que nous avons en france
plus de médecins formés que dans les
autres états de l'union européenne
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que l'
équilibre territorial n'est pas assurée
alors concrètement concrètement il faut
que nous mettions une mesure simple qui
excelle de ne pas pouvoir remplacer un
médecin situé sur une zone géographique
sur densifier d'un point de vue médical
les maisons que les professionnels de
santé
c'est une avancée majeure cela a permis
davantage installations de médecins que
le départ en retraite nous devons
poursuivre dans cette voie et vous
devons encourager ce que j'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure le développement de la
télémédecine qui permet d'en faire les
examens réalisés ce qui permet des
examens à distance avec les meilleurs
spécialistes du chu ou de
l'agglomération tourangelle
voilà une heure un quasiment de débats à
couteaux tirés ce second tour promet
d'être très très serré d'autant que
chacune revendique le soutien du parti
des manuels macro